now ours is a precious and unique
relationship when it comes to the
routine arming of the police and is to
be messed with that everyone's peril
however I believe the time for change
has come recent Home Office figures show
a police officer in this country is
under threat of some form of assault
every 20 minutes actual physical attacks
and officers have more than doubled in
some parts of the UK that is why it is
time for tasers to be provided to all
officers who request them this is a
non-lethal deterrent firing a fifty
thousand volt charge into and then
incapacitating a possible assailant they
have already saved officers lives and
just as importantly can help keep the
public safe as it empowers officers to
control potentially dangerous situations
currently women and boys in blue are
equipped with a baton pepper spray a
radio and some cable ties that makes
them resemble a little more than a bunch
of aggressive gardeners it is time for
tasers can I start by saying that I
absolutely agree that the issue of
police officer safety is one we should
all take seriously and I've been as
appalled as I think everyone to see
footage of police officers being
attacked in our streets so I totally
agree with the premise of having this
discussion but Nick I'm so disappointed
that you're supporting a call for more
Tasers one of my closest friends a
lawyer very senior lawyer named Barry or
Kobe lost her brother last year in the
Bay Area in California he was a 36 year
old poet who was walking down the street
when police officers told him to move
onto the pavement and when he refused he
was tasered effectively to death he is
one of ten people in that County alone
that has been killed by Tasers in recent
months there are so many cases like this
in America which is a country I know
you've been looking to in your campaign
that uses Tasers you know that black men
of that age are 9 times more likely to
be killed by the police
and in this country there is also
evidence that black people are
disproportionately at the receiving end
of force by the police now the problem
three times more likely to be tasered
now the problem with Tasers is in
friend's brother's case the district
attorney said that there was actually no
need for this person to be killed yeah
it was lawful anyway and you know what
that means that means that it's
essentially lawful for the police to
kill people with Tasers
even if they can't prove it was a
necessary or disproportionate use of
force now I am so worried about the idea
of this potentially lethal weapon 50,000
volts of electricity being widely
available among a large number of whom
fail the training they received you say
it's not a light option it's a serious
weapon and it leads to death and
especially deaths of black people and I
cannot support any cool to see my youth
horrified to hear your personal instance
and obviously you have my commiserations
and thoughts there
I think if on reflection to like and
British policing to us policing is a
little a little unfair I would argue
that we perhaps have greater restraint
if I can use this expression they may be
slightly more gung-ho in the u.s. than
they are in the UK as regards the people
well the officer will only deploy a
Taser or neeterb or those who are
committing crime the Taser itself sees
no color so you will only use them if
you're having to restrain people who are
doing that do you know that one in five
people killed by police in the US have
mental health issues there there are
there are there are also if you look at
the case the people killed by the police
here people with mental health issues or
experiencing a mental health episode are
highly over-represented the idea that
there's no the police the police only
deploy tasers or force if somebody is
committing an offense that justifies
that previously and you were kind enough
to say that you said you respected me
because I mention it I've been arrested
falsely at gunpoint by Essex police when
I was 15 years old yes it was a
terrifying experience I have grown up
being spat at by police and being called
racist names in the bad old days of
racism in this country now much has
changed and I can see you really going
to come to the chapter okay please
understand I'm going to make a
connection 48 percent according to
Cambridge University police that while
phasers were 48 percent more likely to
use them and aggressive interactions
with members of the public went up both
at the City of London study and the
Cambridge University study because it's
known as the weapons effect right
there's a psychological effect that
occurs when weapons are on display that
both sides become more aggressive now
three times more likely deploy taser
doesn't see color then we need another
explanation for why black men are three
times more likely to be tasered in MAGIX
making a very valid point that one of
the reasons that our police are
different to American police is because
they are not armed to the same extent
and there is evidence that the more you
armed officers the more aggression
becomes heightened on both just finish
my sentence I say that actually so I
would require an answer to those two
studies before I can almost every city
in this country there is a growing daily
threat to frontline officers an officer
is attacked in this country every 20
minutes we cannot expect police to keep
awesome themselves safe armed with a
baton and a cheery smile
it's not gonna work anymore it's just
not gonna work we can't have officers
more importantly we can't have them
feeling vulnerable there was there was a
survey of the Police Federation recently
93% of officers said they thought
frontline officers should be armed with
Tasers
this is very important because it's we
can't ask police to walk into violent
potentially lethal situations with
nothing all right Rach I'm coming to you
after let's hear someone who's actually
charged with her - looking after some of
our police services I refer to anti
Stansfield who's the police and crime
Commissioner for Thames Valley but
criminals with guns especially knives
are more difficult to take very good
from carrying all priests carrying
firearms where somebody's have been
called in the first place and people
straight I'll show you me firing taser a
little bit later we want to hear from
you Red John well I think this idea that
you know the the Taser doesn't see color
is absurd when we consider you know that
it's not happening in a vacuum we're
talking about a context of structural
and systemic racism and into that it's
no great surprise that these things
including stop and search are used
disproportionately against people of
color but I want to change this I want
to move that slightly because we're
looking at we're looking at issues of
law and order and you keep suggesting
more and more punitive ways to deal with
the issue and I accept that's a real
issue and and police should not have to
have their lives threatened in that way
I agree why do we look at the wider
issue of why that's happening again
social inequality why don't we try and
tackle it from the from the point of
harm reduction we're treating it from
treating it as a public health issue
rather than a punitive issue so we start
looking at social services mental health
issues we start looking at why there's
no youth services more crime how does
that help to cops with a stop tonight in
Birmingham because yes police are more
and more police being attacked in fact I
think it's 27% increase we can have a
look at this figure a 27% increase in
assaults of police officers in England
and Wales yeah that's true that's based
on a study some of the studies that say
hostility in violence goes up when you
arm police so it won't help them with
what you're trying to help unless you
provide me further my Dirty Harry moment
here's me on the firing range in New
Jersey I want you to say the word taser
taser taser three times well we're gonna
do that course we let people around know
that we're gonna actually be exposing
someone to a Taser and we're letting
that subject know - we're gonna hit him
with that taser now right right he might
decide okay this isn't worth it and or
and I don't want to continue this attack
taser taser now switch the safety off
immediately the stop yes the middle
class shouting taser taser taser former
New Jersey cop who's taking me through
my paces there I will just refer that
one New York cop I said and I said to
him how would you feel going out without
your gun he said you'd be asking me to
patrol without my shoes it should be
different here over there a good reason
because the US has pioneered the use of
taser and it's also pioneered the use of
unlawful deaths at the hands of the
police you talked about police not ninis
feel vulnerable like why should why
should innocent black people feel
vulnerable people are more likely to be
tasered
entire debate just so you could clip
shows that clip